oh yeah you can just okay you can just
put your stuff there really nice place
you got here yeah it's not bad hey i you
got a spooky skeleton guy oh yeah his
name's karl marx oh from like uh the the
comp the communism yeah i
i get that reference well well well
what's what's this we have here oh
that's my couch i've never seen a couch
like this before i mean i think it's
pretty normal by most standards i'm
gonna stand on it joel no i'm going to
stand on it joel don't stand on it no
[Music]
can you please get down what's wrong you
didn't even take your shoes off yes i
did
oh
well you could still break it how could
i break it you could break it i i don't
know it's not designed for that what
it's not designed to support the full
weight of my body i don't know i'm gonna
kill you right now
why did you say that like a question
what oh it's in the script
[Applause]
i'm gonna i'm gonna kill you right now
oh that's that's typo
my bad why are you showing the script
it's it's getting too meta we're
parodying joel haver he does meta stuff
like this like all the time no he
doesn't he does watch ralphie get down
from there or the even more underrated
classic ralphie get down from there
again if we're parodying joel haver why
why aren't we doing one of the animated
ones isn't that is that like the most
popular one oh i don't i don't know how
to animate things i'm not good at that
well what about like one of the
old-timey ones did you try that what an
unusual situation i find myself in it
didn't work well what do you want to do
what do you mean what do you want to do
you're me i'm just you but like 20
minutes after shaving wait but what do i
do if i mess up this part and then i
have to reshoot it
later without the beard i'll think of
something i don't know okay how should
we end this i i figured we could like uh
just have a light moment just like start
laughing
and then cut to subscribe for weekly
short films oh yeah i like how he does
that it's really classic
classy
i messed up the line it's okay
oh my god
all right let's okay one more one more
time one more take
you